thank you
good afternoon dear colleagues can I ask
you to take your seats
dear colleagues this is an important
moment can I please ask you to take your
seats
this season
okay thank you can I ask the
photographers to
to go a little bit to the side please
dear
laureates of the 2022 Sahara prize for
freedom of thought
dear Ambassador chensoff an ambassador
tarasyuk dear Alexandra Yulia Ivan
Alexander
stanislav and yaroslav representing the
brave people of Ukraine
dear 2022 sucker of prize finalists dear
colleagues it is my privilege to welcome
you all to the European Parliament for
the 2022 saharov prize award ceremony
since 1988 the Sahara of prize for
freedom of thought has paid tribute to
people and organizations that fight in
the name of Freedom around the world a
fight that is synonymous with the legacy
of scientists and Russian dissident
Andrei saharov of whom this prize Bears
name to Andrei saharov firmly believed
in a world of open free and Democratic
societies the same belief that underpins
our way of European life it was under
Andre saharov himself that once said a
country which does not respect the
rights of its own citizens will not
respect the rights of its neighbors this
is a message that remains as relevant as
ever that is why in 2020 this European
Parliament awarded it desire of price to
the belarussian Democratic opposition
represented by the leader of the
Belarusian Democratic movement Svetlana
taranovskaya and political activist
Veronica sapkala to this day Belarus
holds the appalling record of having the
highest number of Sahar of prize
laureates in prison
this is also why in 2021 the European
Parliament awarded the Sahara of price
to Russian opposition leader Alexei
navani for his fight against the
kremlin's abuse and here again I take
the opportunity to call for his
immediate and unconditional release
our message is that we will not forget
them we will not forget any of our
Sahara of prize laureates who are still
paying the price for Freedom this year
we meet to honor our 2022 Sahara of
prize laureates the brave people of
Ukraine represented by their president
elected leaders and Civil Society
ukrainians who have already fought hard
and sacrificed so much for their freedom
and our values and so was an
introduction to this award ceremony I
invite you all to watch a short video on
the laureates of the Sahara of prize for
freedom of thoughts
[Music]
it's a crane
it is a country of real people strong
and courageous
people who felt their strength and
showed the world an example of
resilience and perseverance
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
you know we have a desire for our
children to live
[Music]
dear friends
dear friends today marks the
293rd day of war in Ukraine
we have witnessed the inspiring
resistance of ordinary citizens making
the ultimate sacrifice to delay a column
of Tanks senior citizens standing up to
face down Russian troops with nothing
but Pride as their weapons Brave women
forced to give birth in underground
Metro stations
to these people the message from Europe
has been clear we stand with Ukraine we
will not look away
the Ukrainian people are not just
fighting a war of independence but
fighting a war of values the values
which underpin our life in the European
Union and that we have long had the
luxury of taking for granted each and
every day
we often speak about democracy Freedom
Liberty as if they were some abstract
Concepts that do not really translate
into much in practice but the ability to
vote for who we believe in
to read independent journalism
to assemble and to say what we want to
say
to disagree and dissent to pursue
whatever gives us most happiness in life
to live and love as we choose without
consequences these are what democracy
freedom and liberty mean and the
Ukrainian people deserve to have that
too
this is why this is why I went to Kiev
to assure president zelenski and
everyone in the verhof Narada that this
European Parliament will stand alongside
Ukraine in this fight this is why we
send Financial
humanitarian and Military age to Ukraine
and why we will continue to send more
this is why we adopted eight and soon
nine hard-hitting packages of sanctions
against Putin and his enablers and
continue to amplify your calls to have
Russia pay for its war crimes this is
why we granted Ukraine EU candidacy
status and defied every cynic who
thought our Unity would not hold and
dear friends this is why today we are
awarding the European Parliament most
prestigious prize for freedom and human
rights to the brave people of Ukraine
represented by their president elected
leaders and Civil Society because once
again we mean it when we say that we
will stand in Ukraine's corner and I
know that we will have to continue doing
more but let's today award serve as a
reminder of our unwavering support and
let it be dedicated to all those Brave
Ukrainian women and men on the ground to
all those who have welcomed with Open
Hearts into our homes and to all those
who have lost their beloved family and
friends and I know that the brave people
of Ukraine will not give up and let me
assure you that neither will we Slava
ukraini
it is now my immense honor to give the
floor to the president of Ukraine
volodimir zelenski president zelenski
you have the flaw
s
foreign
[Music]
foreign
thank you
thank you Roberta
thank you
esteemed Madam president dear Roberto
dear friends
our great shoe on behalf of all our
people
it's a great honor
I greet you on behalf of those who are
fighting who work for the sake of
Ukraine and for the sake of freedom
for the sake of what it is impossible
to imagine all of us
for all of us life in Europe it is
impossible to imagine it without Ukraine
without freedom and not only because it
would be simply untrue but also because
any attempt
to deprive Europe of Ukraine and freedom
is always a crime
and wheat such a crime now
Russia's terrorists war against Ukraine
and Europe
it was also in the past when Turin is
tried to conquer ukrainians and deprive
all Europeans of their freedom
but when we
win now
ukrainians and all Europeans
were will win in such a way that there
will never be attempts to deprive Europe
over Ukraine and freedom
we will we will win so that there will
be no attempts to apply again the
genocidal policy against our people
both a new trade and throughout Europe
we must give and we will give a new
effective security architecture for
Global freedom and international law and
order I believe this is part of our
moral duty
look at how the Russian army is
advancing the occupies are burning
everything in front of them
with artillery and missiles bombs and
drones mines and ammunition and exploded
ammunition that remain in our land
the occupants are destroying cities and
Villages all vital infrastructure
it happened in mariupal you all saw it
it was the same in vulnervara
another city completely destroyed after
the Russian offensive
more than 20 000 people lived there
before this war
now it is a total rune
the Russian is honors doing the same
with bakmut another city in donbass
where Russian strikes live just broken
stones and more than 70 000 people
used to live there
until recently
last year
now it is in Ruins
perhaps
only after the end of this war
when we liberate all of our land
and we will be able to find
all the graves of the victims of Russian
Terror will be able to say how many
lives tyranny
has taken this time
now we know thousands of names of the
victims unfortunately there may be more
many more I ask you all to observe a
minute of Silence in memory of all
Ukrainian men
and women all adults and children all
military and civilians whose lives were
taken by this Russian war
by this deplorable War
thank you very much
dear friends we must act now not waiting
for the war to end to bring to Justice
all those who Unleashed it and to
prevent any repetition of aggression
this will be the most effective
protection of Freedom human rights the
rule of law and other common values
which are embodied in particular by this
award of the European Parliament the
sucker of prize
I'm grateful to everyone who
investigates and helps to investigate
the crimes of the occupiers of Ukraine
of Ukraine who's looking for information
about Russian murderers and terrorists
I'm grateful to the international
criminal court which closely cooperates
with Ukrainian prosecutors and has a
clear intention to bring Justice
to the crimes committed by the occupiers
on the territory of our state and I'm
grateful to all leaders and States all
politician all politicians and
international organizations that work
together with us and make every effort
to establish the Tribunal for the crime
of Russian aggression against Ukraine
I call on all of you your parties and
states to effectively support this work
the tribunal must start working the
European Parliament has already
supported this idea it is necessary to
make it a reality as soon as possible in
particular through a the adoption of a
separate European Parliament resolution
in support for the establishment of the
tribunal through your support and
support of the relevant U.N General
Assembly resolution by your countries
the cities and Villages destroyed by
Russia destroyed lives broken and short
lives should be reflected in the
sentences not only for those who
directly committed all this but also for
those who organized and started this
aggression
and when the principle of inevitable
inevitable inevitable inevitability of
punishment will work for the crime of
aggression against Ukraine we'll be able
to make the appropriate institutional
basis of Justice permanent when any
potential aggressor knows that
punishment for a criminal war is
inevitable it will be the most effective
tool for war prevention
and one more thing
historical responsibility evil always
has a motive to return When the history
of evil is not fully written
dear members of parliament I know that
tomorrow you will be considering the
issue of recognizing the holiday more
crime against the Ukrainian people as
genocide and I urge you to support such
recognition with the maximum majority of
votes to establish justice Europe must
give this strongest possible signal that
there will be no Gap in the history of
tragedies on our continent
in the history of crimes against
humanity and Humanity committed in our
land
I believe that it will be so thank you
for your support thank you for
supporting it and celebrating our
struggle thank you personally
for marking our struggle thank you
personally Roberto for supporting us you
came to care in a difficult and
Dangerous Time
for supporting our reforms that you
thank you for supporting our movement to
European structures and a really help in
really helping thank you
glory to our all our soldiers glory to
each and everyone who defends freedom in
our people
glory to Ukraine
[Applause]
foreign
thank you
thank you
thank you
[Applause]
thank you
[Applause]
foreign
thank you
thank you dear colleagues we proceed
with the vote
foreign